the sun is the major source of heat and
light for every creature on our planet
its rays feed plants
warm the ground
turn glaciers into mountain rivers and
move air masses around to create a
refreshing breeze
billions of kilometers away from us
other stars give hate to other planets
which are different from our earth quite
in the same manner
but there are worlds out there that are
completely independent from any star
their sky will never be lit by sunrise
and their surfaces are shrouded in an
eternal night
they're destined to billions of years of
solitaryness in the cold expanses of the
cosmos
and only silvery clouds made up of
finest ice needles as it were hang over
the dark horizon
cosmo
the first in outer space
assumptions about the existence of space
objects the size of a planet which are
independent from any star have been
around for a long time
such celestial objects freely drifting
around interstellar space are referred
to as orphan free-floating or rogue
planets
astronomical bodies of this kind emit
very little thermal and light energy
into space around them it is suggested
that there are no bodies in their close
proximity they could clearly interact
with or be bound to
that is why it is hardly surprising that
these objects are so difficult to detect
the first potential representatives of
this class of planets were spotted as
recently as in the early 21st century
the warmest rogue planets can be
detected with infrared telescopes and
others thanks to something called the
gravitational microlensing effect as one
would expect
this class of celestial objects is one
of the most mysterious and understudied
today only three astronomical bodies can
be classified as rogue planets with a
sufficient degree of certainty with the
overall number of rogue planet
candidates over two dozen
incidentally according to the analysis
of data collected in the course of the
ogle project the milky way may
supposedly be home to up to 100 billion
objects of this class
this may only mean that right now we're
at the very beginning of an upcoming
series of discoveries in this field
our notions of what rogue planets are
like have long been based purely on
assumptions and hypotheses
with the technological advancement of
highly sensitive observation equipment
there arose opportunities to put them to
the test in practice
the rogue planet lying closest to the
earth among those already confirmed
is known as y0855-0714
7.27 light years away from the sun it
was detected in 2014 with a wise orbital
infrared telescope
the astronomical body cannot be seen
through optical telescopes as it emits
no visible light to speak of
the reason for this is its extremely low
temperature
from 225 to 260 kelvin
or 48 to 13 degrees celsius below zero
in terms of its parameters it resembles
a cooled off gas giant and its age
cannot be under a billion years
the rogue planet is mostly made up of
hydrogen
however in 2016 the gemini observatory
produced evidence of the presence of
large amounts of water in its atmosphere
it is suggested that water is condensed
into clouds made up of tiniest particles
of ice
today it hasn't been established for
certain how the subject came to be
there are currently two versions
suggested by researchers
according to the first one a celestial
object like that starts its life cycle
in the protoplanetary disk of a regular
planetary system
mathematical modeling of this process
shows that if the original cloud of gas
and dust is heavy enough it is highly
likely that at least one planet will be
ejected beyond the system
the celestial object may also be forced
out of its stars environs if another
massive star passes it by or else if its
planetary system collides with another
system
the chances of events like that are
admittedly comparatively small
the other version has it that the space
object was born just like any other star
on compression of interstellar gas
at the same time the mass of the object
proved to be too small to unleash any
thermonuclear reactions in its interior
it goes without saying that in this
manner it may turn out only as a gas
giant or a brown dwarf but not a rocky
planet similar to the earth
some researchers don't agree that these
objects should be seen as rogue planets
and classify them as sub-brown dwarves
instead
others suggest using the term planemo
for all interstellar wanderies that
don't show any thermonuclear activity
bearing in mind today's notions of the
makeup of brown dwarves and gas giants
we may estimate the mass of
ys0855-0714 at anything from three to
ten jupiter masses
this rather falls short of starting a
thermonuclear reaction but quite enough
to keep the heat effectively trapped
inside the planet
taking into account our knowledge about
natural laws we can predict what the
conditions on the astronomical body's
surface are like
for example according to research by
david john stevenson from the university
of california in the u.s gas giants
similar to jupiter don't cool off
instantly after receding from their star
their thick hydrogen atmosphere is quite
reliable thermal isolation while the
dense and hot nucleus made up of
metallic hydrogen can keep the planet
heated for a considerable time
estimates show that the temperature of
the lowest strata of a hypothetical
celestial object's atmosphere may be
high enough for liquid water to be
around
it is likely to be present in the
atmosphere as giant clouds made up of
tiniest droplets
these deductions agree with the results
of mathematical modelling of wise 0855
minus 714 carried out by a team of
scientists from the university of
edinburgh it showed that the most likely
temperature value of the planet's
surface is 250 kelvin or 23 degrees
celsius below zero
the celestial body's atmosphere also has
a comparatively warm layer around 100
kilometers thick whose density
fluctuates from 0.4 to 1.2 milligrams
per cubic centimeter
it is comparable with the conditions on
the earth and so it is thought that this
environment should be favorable for
potential organic life
incidentally a planet doesn't have to be
a massive gas giant to avoid freezing in
the cosmos in 2020 a rogue planet
candidate was detected using
gravitational microlensing techniques
and here is the long designation it got
it is still awaiting confirmation of the
rogue planet's status and its parameters
have been defined only generally so far
according to preliminary data however
the object is comparable to the earth in
terms of its mass and is anything from
30 to 180 000 light years away
according to our current scientific
notions
an object with a mass like that is not
supposed to be a gas giant and is more
likely to be a rocky planet
this in its turn offers good grounds to
believe that the object formed in the
protoplanetary disk of a planetary
system as the latter was forming it may
have been ejected from the system as a
result of a cataclysm in space or
alternatively under the influence of a
larger neighbor
after that it was left to its own
devices and so became a free-floating
planet
what will happen to it next is
predefined by a combination of several
factors
provided the object's atmosphere is
sufficiently dense it will be reliably
thermally isolated
potentially a layer of ice on its
surface could produce the same isolating
effect
in addition with the object's interior
scorching hot and with radioactive
elements undergoing decay
most of the hypothetical ocean will
remain in a liquid state
if the planet happened to have a moon it
may have retained it on ejection
if this is the case tidal forces are
likely to continue to deform and warm up
the lithosphere
theoretically with any luck primitive
anaerobic life forms may have stayed
around although of course it would be
next to impossible to discover their
traces now
most of the data about the rogue planets
we know today were arrived at following
mathematical modelling and complex
calculations
it was possible to do these calculations
thanks to the tiniest bits of
information gleaned with the help of
orbital and earth-based telescopes
even as i speak a project is being
worked on known as cleopatra
its main objective will be to search for
free-floating planets and other objects
in space with subsequent definition of
their parameters
the project relies on something called
microlensing it is a phenomenon when a
celestial body passes between a remote
star and the observer on the earth and
briefly interferes with the light
emitted by the remote star in the
background
when observed from different angles the
moment of transition will be registered
a fraction of a second sooner in one
observatory than in another
referred to as lensing parallax this
effect allows scientists to gauge the
distance to a detected object as well as
its mass and dimensions
an interplanetary spacecraft is planned
to be created within the project it is
supposed to blast off the surface of the
earth as soon as in 2025 alongside a
mission to mars
after which it will enter its own orbit
around the sun
the project will be aided by a
specialized artificial intelligence
component whose mission will be to
process and analyze collected
information
the clerpatra project will certainly
delight us with a wealth of exciting and
important information so there is a lot
to look forward to
what is to become of all those rogue
worlds out there
drifting quite by themselves in the dark
depths of the universe
in theory a northern planet may be
captured by the gravitational field of a
star and become part of its planetary
system
but this chance is by all accounts
minuscule
most objects like that are destined to
wander for billions of years through
endless expanses of space while slowly
and inevitably cooling off
eventually
they're to be swallowed up by black
holes or else destroyed as a result of a
cataclysm in space never to reveal their
secrets to mankind
[Music]
[Music]
you